We are all trying to figure out how to pay for those pricey visits...
...to friends and family this holiday season.
Don't let those high prices get you down.
Travel expert Mike Siegel is showing us three money-saving travel ideas...
...to beat that holiday rush.
First up, be tardy to the party.
Flying on Christmas day, flying on New Year's Day, New Year's Eve,...
...you can get a big deal.
Even though your holiday meal might be a bit cold when you arrive,...
...Mike says you can save 50% or more on tickets if you wait.
And for your flight back,...
...Travelzoo researchers says December 31st and January 6th are your cheapest bets.
The next travel-saving technique: book tickets separately.
Getting big blocks of tickets with the airline is a tough thing.
If you're gonna buy that, usually they're not gonna give you any kind of deal.
And finally, stay at a business hotel.
So check out hotel chains like Holiday Inn Express and Residence Inn.
Business hotels really take a beating over the holidays...
...because no one's traveling for business.
So if you're willing to stay in more of an industrial park area or a business area,...
...they'll give deals.
Many of the big chain business hotels drop their rates by 30% around the holidays.